in this present crisis
government is not the solution to our
problem
government is the problem
ask not what your country can do for you
ask what you can do for your country
[Applause]
[Music]
we've had this event during wars we've
had it during depression
we'll have it during a pandemic as
president reagan said the first time he
was sworn in 40 years ago
that this event is both commonplace and
miraculous
commonplace because we've done it every
four years since 1789
and miraculous because we've done it
every four years
since 1789.
against the backdrop of a pandemic
january 20th 2021 was set to be an
inauguration for the history books
that was before a pro-trump mob rampaged
the u.s capitol on january 6th
and disrupted the vote to certify joe
biden's 2020 presidential election win
you now have an inaugural that's
literally going to take place
on the steps of the capitol that was
ransacked
a few days earlier by a mob trying to
prevent the very inaugural that's taking
place
i think there is a tendency to kind of
overstate the drama of most moments
there's a tendency to hype them a little
bit if you will
i think this one is kind of hard to hype
i think the drama is legitimate
while president-elect joe biden's
inauguration will certainly look
different the u.s has sworn in
presidents at times of high national
drama and deep political division before
so how will biden's moment fit into
history
[Music]
we all know as americans what that
tableau is supposed to look like a
crowded dice with the new president and
the outgoing president both there
with a lot of dignitaries in the supreme
court and a big crowd
down below we're not going to have all
of those things
the coronavirus pandemic has
fundamentally changed how we live
and the tradition of the inauguration is
not being spared
as the u.s nears 400 000 deaths from the
virus
the inaugural has been adjusted
dramatically guests will be limited the
luncheon has been canceled and the
parade will be virtual
senator roy blunt chairs the
congressional inauguration committee
inauguration of the president of the
united states
i think we're going to have somewhere in
the neighborhood of 2500 to 3 000 people
at the inauguration as opposed to 200
000
following the capital riot security is
being beefed up at least 20 000 national
guardsmen were sent to washington dc
ahead of the inauguration
that's more than twice the number sent
for president obama's inauguration when
security concerns were also high
both president-elect biden and i and his
team
are in agreement that uh events
of the attack on the capital make it
even more important
uh that we're outside we're at the place
where people are used to seeing the
inauguration of the president
one president who won't be attending is
president trump who with a week
remaining in his term became the first
president to be impeached for a second
time
after he was accused of encouraging a
mob to storm the capital in an effort to
overturn the election
there's going to be an air of tension
the question of whether democrats and
republicans
having just been through this trauma at
the capitol together
will look as if they're unified or not
will be a question hanging over an event
in which people always put on a face of
unity will that be the case this time or
not
like many presidents before him biden
will enter office at a time of
heightened national drama
hi gerald are poor do solemnly swear
but some of the most dramatic times have
seen some of the most memorable
inaugural addresses in history
jump back to 1865. lincoln's
second inaugural that occurred during
the civil war produced probably the
greatest
inaugural speech of all he said to the
country
it is time to bind our wounds we must
heal
and it was exactly the message the
country needed to hear
at that time it's also one that stood
the test of time
nearly 70 years later the u.s in the
midst of the great depression
elected franklin d roosevelt for the
first time at his inauguration he
addressed the nation
now famously saying the only thing we
have to
fear is fear itself
in both cases lincoln and roosevelt were
trying to persuade americans that the
drama of the moment
could be overcome that is similar in
some ways do i think the atmosphere we
have now where people are saying can our
democracy
survive the inaugurals are designed to
lift up washington
a moment in which everybody can be
optimistic we'll see if
joe biden can pull off that in this
strange environment
in 2000 the highly contested election
between george w bush and al gore went
all the way to the supreme court and
wasn't decided until december
a month before the inauguration finally
a president-elect
george w bush will become the 43rd
president of the united states
it fell to george w bush to say this is
a divided
country politically there's controversy
over my election
he didn't say it but he knew that some
people thought he wasn't even
legitimately elected because he hadn't
won the popular vote
he used his inaugural to say i recognize
that their deep wounds left by this
election i will help
us all move past them our unity
our union is the serious work of leaders
and citizens and
every generation and this is my solemn
pledge
i will work to build a single nation of
justice
and opportunity trump faced a similarly
divided country when he took office in
2017.
like bush he won the electoral college
but lost the popular vote
in his speech however he took a
different approach in addressing this
divide
and the crime and the gangs and the
drugs
that have stolen too many lives and
robbed our country
of so much unrealized potential
this american carnage stops
right here and stops
right now rather than really trying to
soothe the political passions he some
ways he ramped him up he said basically
america is a place that is hurting it is
uh it has been hurt by you people the
political establishment
there's a dark america out there that
needs to be changed i'm going to change
it from this day
forward it's going to be only
america first
now as biden takes office he is facing a
still divided country
a poll last month found roughly
one-third of those surveyed did not
think biden won the election
legitimately
and about the same share believed there
was widespread voter fraud
just so you understand this election was
a fraud trump has repeated both of these
false claims
he's conceded that he's not going to be
the president any longer but he has not
conceded that he lost the election
that is uh going to convey in the eyes
of millions of americans
a sense of illegitimacy about a
president biden and the biden
administration
this inauguration seems poised to hold a
unique place in our country's history
how president biden tries to speak to
people who think he is not the
legitimate next president of this
country
is going to be an important part of this
inaugural i pledge to be a president
who seeks not to divide but unify
i think people will look back on the
2021 inauguration of joe biden and say
that was the one and only inauguration
this country has ever had
that went that way i can't imagine this
set of circumstances
ever being repeated